welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down Starship Troopers
released in 1997 this was a big staple
of my childhood with the movie Becoming
one of my favorites from the entire
decade I love the over-the-top action
insane Gore and the coming of age story
about our hero Johnny Rico at the time
the subtext completely went over my head
and when watching it as an adult I
realized there was a completely
different light of the movie that my my
nine-year-old brain just didn't pick up
on Paul verhoven is a master of satire
and for me this Rivals his classic
RoboCop in terms of subtext in parody
now what I love about the movie is that
you can enjoy it as an over-the-top
action flick or watch it for its more
cerebral and metaphorical comments
playing up the glorification of War
propaganda and a society centered around
military rule the movies aged
excellently and there's so much that you
can unpack from it would you like to
know more yep I'm guessing you would and
throughout this breakdown we'll be going
through Starship Troopers seen by Cena
talk about all the hidden layers within
it that make it a masterpiece although
firstly I want to do what I always do
with these videos which is to talk about
how the movie was actually made now you
might not know this but Starship
Troopers is actually based off the back
of a novel of the same name from 1959
originally called Starship Soldier this
was created by Robert a Heinlein and
published as a two-part serial in the
magazine of fantasy and science fiction
said in the far future we join a
civilization that's built itself into a
Utopia though it seems perfect descent
is squashed down and the military Elite
rule overall in order to be classed as a
citizen one must enlist in the Army and
from a young age students are
brainwashing and thinking that it said
you did a fight like the movie the enemy
comes in the form of an alien species
known as the bug which Humanity uses its
technology to attack another film
definitely has the aspects of criticism
with this from all the research I could
find Highland was actually in favor of
it according to several deconstructions
of the book he actually thought that
there'd been a moral decline in Western
society and that military service was
the way to create a stronger one
Highland actually served in the Navy for
five years and he openly spoke out
against President Eisenhower's decision
to stop U.S nuclear tests now it is
difficult to fully gauge his intentions
as like the movie it doesn't really
support or condemn it just paints out a
society where the world is the way it is
and kind of asks you to make up your own
mind on it the book has been described
as fascist due to exploring the idea of
limiting the right devote to certain
people but there's other critics that
have disagreed they say that Heinlein is
exploring the idea of what Society would
be like if we limited voting to just
certain people the books share a hive
mind as well and this has been said to
be Heinen expressing his anti-communist
views he was staunchly against it and
though there was a lot of controversy
with both the book and the author he
still remained one of the most popular
us writers of the 40s and 50s he also
won a Hugo award for it in the 1960s and
thus this box been ripe for an
adaptation and the source material
actually tells things in a
non-chronological order with a movie
sorting these events out to become more
linear the buckar winds with Rico and
his group of quote-unquote Roughnecks
carrying out a raid in which dizzy dies
Dizzy's actually a man in this and from
here we get flashbacks to his graduation
where we can see that he enlists because
it's gonna annoy his dad this could also
potentially put him together with his
classmate comment but as we see she goes
on to become a pilot now from here his
training begins with the military using
armored suits the book is actually
credited with popularizing these in
science fiction as they hadn't really
been seen before in any of the genre
although Buenos Aires is attacked by the
bugs it's only actually Johnny's mother
who dies his dad actually ends up
Surviving and he enlists in the Army
which shows how his attitude towards the
military was wrong the book ends with
them all arming up and heading out to
the Battle of clendathe in what's about
to be a glorious counter-attack
foreign
and the movie began Life as a script
called Bug hundred Outpost 7. since the
release of Robocop producer John
Davidson wanted to reunite the writers
of the film and make a new story
treatment in the same vein developing a
screenplay called Bug hundred Outpost 7
that they wanted to do a sort of Aliens
parody that was about tackling insects
in space with a group of over-the-top
Macho Marines upon pitching it to
Davison he realized how similar it was
to Starship Troopers but he just assumed
that someone else would already have the
rights to it the screenplay was retitled
to just Outpost seven and though it was
an improvement it was still rejected by
all the studios they pitched it to in
the aftermath of this they learned the
rights to Starship troopers were still
available and after they purchased them
they reworked out post 7 to me more in
line with it getting Paul verhoven back
they also brought on Phil Tipper who we
often talk about when we're going
through these classic movie breakdowns
tibeted mount most of the major effects
in the original Star Wars Trilogy and he
also worked on RoboCop alongside the
rest of the team he actually gave a nod
to his prior work in the movie and the
Millennium Falcon can be seen attached
to one of the ships in the behind the
scenes stuff on the VFX now verhalvin
needed to bounce back from the Dismal
performance of show girls and this
seemed like a good fit with a small
sequence called Bug test winning the
studio around the 90-second clip showed
a soldier fighting against two bugs
which was enough to convince try starter
then green like the film they were
apparently Blown Away by the bugs in it
and didn't actually realize they were
made using CGI this was a time in which
the technology was still relatively new
and it made them feel like the film
could change the game so they began
making it and that takes us into the
movie itself which like Beethoven's
RoboCop opens up with a mixture of news
adverts and public service announcements
[Music]
these are really fun ways to get you
ready for a big space romp adventure oh
well wait is that is this this is about
Space Nazis
now these ads convey a lot in a
really short space of time and instantly
let us know a number of things about
society and how they view the bugs the
first thing we see is the federal
network logo and this lets us know
exactly who's in charge if the military
control the news and they control the
information and can therefore create
propaganda that benefits themselves
delays throughout every aspect of
society and even present in the
classroom to indoctrinate the kids when
we first pull out of Johnny's drawing of
him in common we can see the text along
the bottom that says this is fed paint
the textbook he puts over the top of
this has a federation logo on the front
and even Army Lagos are on the walls in
the classroom now later on in the
propaganda pieces we see his kids are
taught to stamp on the bugs whilst the
teacher looks on and laughs maniacally
there's a great video by wisecrack that
talks about how fascism operates in
general and how in the end it applies to
this movie it gave the idea that in
order for people to carry out genocide
they have to be given a common enemy to
Rally behind to allow 1000 power to
start to wipe them out this is summing
at the Nazis weaponized with the Jews
and they turned everyday normal people
into becoming angry and hateful to to
the point where they'd support the mass
murder of millions because they'd been
conditioned to think that way now if we
discovered a planet full of intelligent
life I'm guessing that most people would
be against NASA immediately rolling out
there and copper bombing it instantly in
order for there to be no backlash they'd
first have to convince us it was fine to
do and this would likely come in the
form of propaganda that's what the
Federation is doing here and if a
society is built around War it needs an
enemy to function otherwise it's gonna
completely Collapse by doing this from a
young age the Federation can paint the
bugs adders the enemy and receive
funding for its War efforts which in
turn equals profit they can convince
people that it's their duty to die for
the species and send them off to All by
the millions just to make money we will
talk about whether the bugs are actually
willingly engaging in the war or not
later on but humans have almost become
like a hive mind them ourselves all are
fighting and dying so the rest of the
species can continue and being super
analytical here I noticed something I'd
never picked up on before the big bug is
of course called the brain and it sucks
out the humans in order to kill them I
think there's definitely a double
meaning to humanity being brainless and
potentially following orders without
question throughout now this is
something that's of course been seen in
both positive and negative ways with
people fighting for freedom and ways to
benefit the species however it's also
negatively been summing Humanities done
too with a lot of atrocities carried out
being put down as simply following
orders I feel like verhoven's definitely
leaning more towards that with several
of the uniforms obviously being inspired
by members of the Third Reich propaganda
was something that really came to the
Forefront in the second world war with
this being used as a way to inspire
people to fight for their country
Goebbels weaponize this and though
you're probably rolling your eyes I
think once we point out more of the
examples here you'll likely see it's the
case Albert Harwin was actually born in
1938 and his family moved to the Hague
and the Nazi occupied Netherlands this
was the home of the German headquarters
and this obviously carried out a number
of fascist acts out of this the opening
image of the movie that we immediately
occurred to right after the logo here we
see a legion of soldiers all standing in
line which is actually a visual nod to a
specific Nazi propaganda film that is
the Triumph of the will which even had
the German line in it for I'm doing my
part I'm doing my part we also see a
blonde hair and blue eyed boy enlisted
in the ranks potentially being a play on
the Hitler Youth I promise a promise
will get a bit more fun later on but
yeah it's quickly played up to how
glorious that war is amongst these
moments we also get fairly clips of
Johnny dizzy and Ace slowly introducing
us to the upcoming characters the entire
film is actually made like one of those
old propaganda pieces with him even
hiring actors that all look like models
to play the main parts now I have to say
that in all of the interviews with the
creative team that had absolutely no
point did they mention this has been
being anti-write or anti-left the way
they saw it both sides have the
potential to do this and they actually
also put more left-leaning ideas in the
film too complete General quality is a
thing too with women being able to be
lined up and killed in battle too yay
women going further into politics and
careers also takes them away from being
more likely to be mothers which is
summing up their home and theorize when
discussing this film we see several
women in the movie like Carmen going
against the idea of being a wife or
mother which leads her to being brought
into the battle even when you see stuff
like how Snow White's being marketed
these days it's clear they want to move
him more towards being a strong
independent woman rather than someone
who's obsessed with being a mom I do
kind of find it weird how our love
stories are getting played down more and
more movies and it's kind of like focus
on your career and give up on love so
you can work for a corporation or rather
here be in the Army I think verhoven
kinda read the room a bit on where
things were going and that's just in
general across the entire movie he and
the writers talked about how they
researched a lot of things before making
it and it actually eerily works as an
Iraq war metaphor that wouldn't happen
until half a decade after this but it
shows just how much they had their
fingers on the pulse there's a desert
planet that could be mistaken for the
Middle East 911 metaphors a big war
effort creating profit and Technology
being a factor might be me putting my
own personal analysis on the movie with
all this but I think that's why the
movie In the End works so well
everyone's gonna have a different
interpretation leading to its sparking
conversation where you can agree or
disagree on what you take from the movie
again I don't think it's anti-ride and I
don't think it's anti-left I think it's
just saying both sides have a need to
make money and profit and that's gonna
cost us now from here we cut to a video
on the meteor attack which of course
comes as a big thing later in the movie
we see it's Earth's defenses quickly
shoot them down but no this wasn't the
case when it came to Buenos Aires that's
important to bear in mind that after
this ad we get a time Jump to one year
before showing that this is the response
to the worry of further attacks what it
has done though is allow for the
Federation to use more resources to buff
up space defenses therefore giving more
money to the Army now there's of course
the argument that the bugs didn't carry
out the attack and when you look at the
evidence it might be a false flag we
never get the answer but either way I
don't actually think it matters these
early Clips let us know that Humanity
Seas destroying klendathy was an
imperative but we know there's people
who are staunchly against this due to
being another form of life in the Galaxy
whether the bugs senate or not it
doesn't really matter and what's really
important is how Humanity used the
strike to justify going to war had this
not happened then they might not have
stormed ahead and Buenos Aires is very
much put in place to justify Invasion
whether it's a false flag a mistake a
genuine attack we'll never know but it's
weaponized as a way to give the
Federation more power now the next clip
shows where clendarthy was in space and
the asteroid belt surrounding the planet
the bugs are would have to be able to
not only control this from the planet
but they'd also have to be able to
calculate the distance from Earth
millions of light years away they'd also
have to be able to predict the speed the
asteroid would be moving and also where
our planet was in terms of its position
in Space by the time the meteor got to
us for example where we are right now in
space won't even be where we are in an
hour's time and the bugs would have to
have this all worked out from the second
they fire from across the solar system
it also would have had to do this I
think millions of years ago and yeah I
don't believe that they had a grudge
against us back then they might have
they might have seen the internet and
done an Ultron and being like wipe all
the is out no either way that's an
extremely complex calculation which I
personally doubt they'd ever be able to
pull off not to get all like the bugs
are the good guys but I really doubt
they had anything to do with the
asteroids hitting us oh crap they're
coming okay got him he's gone walk their
corporate shells you idiot I like the
book we start off with a big battle and
watching news report order covering the
story due to the time you want me wibbly
wobbly nature of this flashback this
reporter actually appears later on in
the film and he's the one who covers the
Roughnecks in their Barracks dying in
the opening we see Rico's unit on a part
two and what is he also seemingly dies
along with them now from here we go to a
classroom and watch Michael ironside's
Razz Jax this name actually is pulled
from the novel and it's his Roughnecks
before it later becomes Rico's Michael
Ironside also appeared in verhoven's
Total Recall and there's actually a
recall back directly to that film in the
fight with Arnie ironside's character
loses his arm which is added here as a
little nut to that all of the teachers
here show some form of combat wounds and
this was actually done for a very
specific reason the biology teacher is
blind and the recruiting sergeants lost
his hand in both legs and this shows the
course that often comes with war this
also highlights that these schools on
schools and there were expats goals to
try and recruit more soldiers there
should be a law against using a score
station Raz check rattles off about how
violence accomplishes things Annie also
name drops Hiroshima during his speech
my mother arrested violence never solves
anything really
I wonder what the city fathers of
Hiroshima would say about that now as we
know this was an atomic bomb Target but
there's not really the debate that that
normally comes up when you talk about
this topic it's presented as a positive
and thus you can see why the attack on
glendatheu is fraying that way too now
outside Johnny Goes to kiss Carmen but
she rebuffs this and says not here the
bubble gum thing she did on the FED pain
had its own Point too and this was
expanded on in a deleted scene basically
what it shows is that PDA should be
downplayed and nobody should really be
able to gain attachments to others
sexuality is repressed and relationships
are slightly frowned upon because if you
love someone you might put them above
your country
hey break it up here too there's a place
for that sort of thing
now when we cut to an establishing shot
we get towering skyscrapers and you can
see an eagles sat on top of one of the
buildings Eagles are of course a staple
of the United States but they're also
what Germany used on their symbols too
the Federation badge looks just like
what the Nazis had and again it ties
these two ideas together a common poll
is Johnny by the hand and in a blink and
you'll miss a moment you can actually
see dizzy longingly looking at them but
the name Rico also has a lot going on
with it as does the fact there's lots of
white people down in Buenos Aires now
though we've never actually been given
an answer to what happened with this
Casper Van Diane has given his thoughts
he said that Argentina was famously a
place for Nazi war criminals who fled to
the country after the second world war
Casper actually thought Johnny may be a
descendant of one of those guys but that
doesn't really explain what's happening
with the rest of the population instead
it's thought that the Federation either
invaded or took the land and from this
point they then ousted the locals The
Source material was set during the 23rd
tree but yeah let me know below exactly
what you think and we see school life
playing out with Johnny failing in his
maths test and common throwing up during
a bug dissection it's here that we also
get lip service pay to call possessing
psychic powers as he carries out a card
test with Rico in the hot seat weirdly
Hitler actually had a Jewish psychic in
his inner circle that he used to ask for
advice which this may be built upon in
the back we can also catch Einstein a
famous German scientist though it's
important to point out that he of course
fled the country no learn that his
ferret's name is Cyrano and this kind of
speaks to the character here Cyrano
actually has roots in the story of the
same name that could really speak to
what's going on with Carl Cyrano was a
nerdy guy that fell in love with a woman
but he felt he was too ugly to stand a
chance with her there's another
character called Christian that also
loved her too and Cyrano told them what
to say to make her fall in love with him
the tragedy is that Cyrano could have
won her but due to his lack of
confidence she never got to see the real
him a call actually tries to kiss Carmen
at one point he's always late when he
walks you home to fish for a kiss
I know this is a joke it might have a
deeper meaning anyway that night we see
a sport called jump ball which they
developed as a mix between football and
gymnastics introducing us to Zander this
kind of sets a beloved triangle but the
only thing he gets sucked on is is his
brains hey how was that
tobacco we see Johnny's parents
disapproving and his dad is a line that
foreshadows his future have you lost
your mind I'd rather take 10 Lashes in
Public Square than see you ruin your
life Johnny of course gets punished
later on and he's forced to take 10
lashes after getting one of his Squad
killed Johnny's family don't want him to
join the Army at all and I actually had
a similar talk from my mum when I was
growing up like shilajit right she
didn't even want me playing Medal of
Honor in the Northeast in case I went
off and stormed the beach of Normandy
anyway at the prom We also get this song
I have not been to Paradise
foreign
who scored both this and also RoboCop
now this is actually a cover of David
Bowie's I have not been to Oxford Town
which is sung from the point of view of
a criminal that's murdered a young girl
called Baby Grace unable to come up with
an alibi it's got a really dark side to
it which the poppy song Here is also
meant to him towards in this movie now
the next day everyone's sworn into
Federal service with a friend swearing
to remain Pals forever really shows an
ievity of it and how they're not really
grasping what's about to happen they've
been sold their stream of Adventure and
fun but as we know it gets far more
brutal his parents try to shut this down
and Carmen also talks about her dad's
fears as well you're late my dad hasn't
helped me pack suddenly he's afraid he's
never gonna see me again or something as
we know this does turn out to be true
because he dies during the Buenos Aires
asteroid strike Rico tells Carmen he
loves her but she resists doing it back
because as we mentioned she's kind of
focused on her career because that's
what she's been told she should put
Above All Else and from here we cut to
another broadcast and get Soldier
showing assault rifles to kids with
attacks a world that works right over
the top of it
a lot to impact from that with the kids
playing with guns like their toys and
desperately trying to grab the bullets
they're obviously getting indoctrinates
using weapons and believing that this is
how a society should work and next we
see a story covering the trial and
execution of a murderer a murderer was
captured this morning and tried today
listen to that again closely a murderer
was captured this morning and tried
today we also get an advertisement for
his execution at 6 PM meaning that he
was caught tried and killed in less than
24 hours that's no time at all to carry
an investigation or or even submit an
appeal and it shows how their society
really operates every aspect of the
state is completely unquestionable and
even appeals to death sentences aren't
given because they rule overall now to
that we get a psychic advert playing off
the test Rico took before we learn that
Mormons established a base on clendathu
this led to an entire Colony being wiped
out and there's a couple of things going
on here that certainly lead into the
propaganda aspects of the piece so it
can control people's emotions I have to
say though that because of YouTube
censorship we've had to blow the bodies
of the colonists but trust me yeah you
see them all ripped open in torn apart
now why this is interesting is because
we see a cow getting ripped up
beforehand but there's a big censored
bar blocking out what's happening the
humans are shown without this though
because psychologically this is expected
to give us a more emotional reaction
than what we would have if we saw an
animal dying and the fact that they went
out here peacefully has also been
weaponized because it shows that you
can't bargain with the bugs and thus
they must be killed now from here we go
to Clancy Brown playing drill sergeant
Sim he Nails the rollers per usual but
again shows a lack of questioning in
this Society he breaks someone's arm for
standing up to him sends a guy to do
laps for laughing draws a knife through
Ace's hand for asking why they need to
do it and after he meets dizzy he nearly
chokes her out nice little detail when
we see her again next and you can
actually catch the bruise around her
throat from where is knee wet I like how
ACE also questions why they need knives
which is something I thought myself
because them bugs tear them apart
however it does actually come into play
and later on we see Carmen using it to
slice the brain bugs spike thing and the
mess hall Ace tries to push in and
Johnny stands up to him which is when
they become mates
you got some guts for a rich kid arico
actually means rich in Spanish and he
constantly gets Tony throughout because
he's got money you rich kids robbed
I did some digging and it turns out that
his parents aren't actually citizens
because they grew up wealthy and
therefore didn't have to fight Johnny
however was persuaded into doing it due
to the Allure unlikely wanting to make
something for himself anyway from here
we go to the shower scene which we're
gonna have to blur again even though
this blew my mind as a nine-year-old lad
this is something where Hoven actually
tried to do in the first RoboCop film
but after it was denied he shifted it to
this this is meant to show the breaking
down of gender barriers but there's also
a lot going on with the imagery and
dialogue you might notice the shower
handles hanging at head height and
they're supposed to resemble nooses
foreshadowing the inevitable death
that's gonna come from serving even
Ace's head is shot so it looks like it's
in the middle of it and this happens at
the point that he says he's going career
later on when Rico's shooting the video
to Carmen he also plays elements of a
funeral march on the violin there's also
all the things that the characters want
to do but in order to achieve them you
have to be a citizen that comes with
politics going to University and even
having kids with one of the characters
saying that you need to have a license
what I like here about the whole I want
to have babies thing is that when she
says this the character who says she's
going into politics starts to roll her
eyes this shows how she's moved away
from the maternal Instinct in order to
be more career driven like what we
talked about before also when I say this
stuff yeah I hope you know I'm not I'm
not bashing it yeah do it do what you
want with your life mate I'm just
analyzing the film and trying to see
what hidden stuff's in it now lastly I
noticed that shijimi said he wanted to
get into Harvard but it would have cost
him an arm and a leg the Federation pay
for it but the soldiers of course have
to make it to the point of leaving later
on when he gets killed his well you
guessed it gets ripped off and this
costs him an actual arm and a leg and we
see the difference between life and the
barracks and Commons adventures in space
with them being polar opposite what it
does though is sell you the illure of
the Federation and all the things you
could experience in it which was one of
the goals that the Hoven made a point to
cover he really wanted to sell you the
belief of what people thought they'd get
when they signed up before plunging you
into the horror of what actual Warfare
is like Johnny gets a taste of this
early on after a victory at the laser
Quasar King of the hell match which is
when he's finally given a squad and we
learn common ship is actually called the
Roger young which is named after a Medal
of Honor recipient young was ordered to
withdraw but he went against this and
destroyed a Machine Gun Nest now she
ends up sending a message out to Johnny
to break up with him after saying that
she's gonna go career I think I'm gonna
go career
signed up on the off chance that he'd
end up with her and this has crushed his
true goals though he never really out
now says it oh
considered because of a girl
common doing this is awesome and
Johnny's plans for a family are on hold
now too and both end up focusing on the
Federation rather than things that might
have been important for them and after
the training exercise goes amiss Rico's
brought in and given a telling off by D
Norris's character Norris and verhoven
worked together before with the actor
also popping up during Total Recall
though they could easily kick him out
lashes are given because Zim thinks that
he's worth keeping Sims actually one of
the heroes of the movie and come the end
of the film we discovered that it was
him who brought the brain bug in he
gives Johnny summoning a bite down on
and even gets himself bust down to
private to fight the bugs himself this
itself could be a call back again to
Roger young who had himself demoted to
go into combat with his men the only
who gets his demotion by ripping up
government documents with Rico's
signature saying that he's now dropping
out reconsider my request to drop out
sir you already signed your 12 48 son it
wouldn't be legal is this your signature
Rico personally
doesn't look like it to me now Rico gets
the lashes Ace gets the squad leader and
to make matters worse comments out in
space getting cozy at this point the
asteroid almost collides with a ship
leading to the top of the aerial coming
off and if you look closely you can
actually see people floating out in
space which unlucky mate now due to the
communication array being gone they
can't contact Earth which is why the
asteroid ends up hitting Buenos Aires at
this point we also see common screen and
if you look closely it has the Voyager
map on it this was actually sent out
into space by NASA on the side of the
Voyager and this was saw that aliens
could find the Earth if they ever came
across it we don't really want them
though yet the stinking bugs we
don't want you on the planet you're
caught
anyway Rico finally makes the call to
his parents and Johnny Goes to leave but
his mind is changed by the attack I know
a couple of people who said that 911
made them enlist and attacks like this
have happened throughout history
something like Pearl Harbor that
actually caused 134 000 Americans to
sign up in the 30 days following it and
just one year after the attack there
were 50 million Americans that were part
of the military this was at a time when
there were about 120 million Americans
in total and it shows there was this
National feeling that it was your duty
to fight back now you see the propaganda
mounting up and extra powers are given
to the government this has been seen in
things like the Patriot Act and it gives
them much more rule over the rest of the
population now we cut that the
journalist who's talking about the Live
and Let Live policy which is instantly
shut down by Johnny Rico and I say Kill
Them All oh yeah the creative team said
they dropped this in to show how
intelligent moral debate is often shut
down by emotionally charged shouting
which often drowns out the other side of
the argument it feels like any actual
Counterpoint is gonna be stomped down in
place of us giving in to our more baser
instincts and the whole Macho idea is
played up even further with them getting
Death from Above tattoos celebrating the
Revenge they're about to get echoing the
drop ships from Aliens we watch as they
mount up and then descend directly onto
the planet I used to have the micro
machines for the easier and the ships
have such a cool design to them this
whole scene definitely feels Cameron
inspired to me and it's at this point
that reality really starts to hit them
we've got people being sick ships
getting hit in space and the campaign on
the planet is a complete massacre in the
shapely tenant Willie says remember
you're training and you'll make it back
alive which should go down as some
famous last words Willie is the first
person to get killed and this kind of
sets tone but just how hopeless the
entire thing is everything is terribly
thought out tactically with it being a
Slaughter on both the soldiers and the
ships the Cruisers fly way too close and
this causes them to crash into each
other and those on the ground have
absolutely no air support to me it shows
how the humans and bugs both act more on
Instinct and that one are actually that
different and not to get all we're not
so different you and I but I feel like
there are mirrors between the species
the brains of the operations are the
upper tears of society with both the
brain bugging people like Carl being the
ones calling the shots they're in the
least amount of danger as they're
normally far from the battlefields and
sending those further down the chain to
fight in their conflicts the next in the
bug hierarchy is the flying ones we see
which Echoes the pilots who too tend to
be further from the danger at the bottom
of the chain are the grunts who are
centered on their thousands and this is
for the needs of the few at the top they
forget just how brutal these first
scenes on the ground are but when you
re-watch it you're really hit with a
horrors of War behaven said he really
wanted to ham up the fun for the first
half of the movie and then hit us with
the reality of it after that first hour
you can pretty much set your watch by it
and clendathy comes at the one hour mark
the director stated he wanted to show
you all this Bloodshed and then at the
end hit you with a China nowad which
would make you ask why you would ever
want to do it and we end the scene with
Johnny seemingly being killed and us
getting the federal network logo
announcing 100 000 dead that's in one
hour alone and because of this disaster
the sky Marshal feels that they have to
resign Humanity goes with the idea that
they have to understand the bug in order
to win and this idea of understanding is
one enemy might be a common on Vietnam
however I feel like it's mainly about
how Humanity's hubris often leads to our
downfall and we're quick to rush ahead
because we confidently think that we're
always gonna come out Victorious the
funny thing is is that humans learn
absolutely nothing from this attack and
they try most of the same things again
on the second one later in the movie now
in between this we get pundits screaming
about what they find offensive brain
bugs frankly I find the idea of a bug
that thinks offensive and yeah I never
really got this back in 97 but the
amount of people in news stations that
get offended over stuff that they bring
on just to make good TV seems to be
built off the back of this now with
Carmen we see she discovers Rico's
apparently killed in action at this
point they were gonna have her in Xander
start a relationship but this was cut
from the film due to test audiences
going mental about it they were very
offended and extremely vocal about it
though you can kind of feel a sort of
thing between the pair throughout the
latter part of the movie now Johnny is
of course alive with him being in a in a
sort of back to tank that riffs on the
one from The Empire Strikes Back dizzy
is of course ecstatic that he's still
alive and I think he starts to realize
he was the real woman for him I think
yeah the big tragedy in this movie is
that dizzy dies and a death scenes
played out far more than the other
characters without passing away in
Johnny's arms at the start of the film
she questioned whether violin solves
anything and the pair could have
probably lived a life together had they
went off to college like what was
originally planned my whole life it like
honestly my whole life I've always found
it head scratching that Johnny Cat
knocking dizzy back but I I guess this
movie ain't exactly painting him out as
the smartest dude look at look at her
math scores you idiot see a chump that
is Johnny Anderson of joining the
razzies what is that is that Gabriel
from The Walking Dead it's bloody
Gabriel amazing anyway dizzy Johnny and
Ace end up joining razzy's ranks with
him saying you don't do your job I'll
shoot you and that takes us into theater
so there are theories that the
lieutenant actually sent its Sergeant to
his death because he wanted to replace
him with Johnny Rico he can catch him
annoying Razz check at several points
and this may be why he sends them up to
the higher ground razak was likely aware
there were bugs on the ground as he saw
rocks tumbling down the cliff which
would have been caused by something
moving up there he then immediately
sends him to put out a radio message
even though he likely knows something's
causing the rubble to fall when the
sergeant is being killed he shoots him
instead of the bug even though he had
more than enough time to kill it before
it ever attacked the sergeant this of
course ties back to the line you don't
do your job I'll shoot you and that
shows that he might have wanted to kill
him for just being crap the sergeant was
also set up to create a Communications
relay even though the Outpost itself was
right around the corner in the end I
feel this wasn't necessary at all and he
might have just been clearing out the
ranks to promote his favorite student
which ends Theory time few time got the
return t-shirt sale right now you want
to look like an idiot with a theory time
T-shirt what got them for you
now this time on the planet we see what
they should have done in the first place
without being heavy carpet bombing
before the troops are sent in I kind of
feel like these moments are meant to
show the bugs in a sympathetic light and
we get one screaming in agony as the
fire burns through it
this almost sounds human like I think it
might actually be humans just screaming
and shortly after when one's wounded we
get a close-up of its eye as it looks
scared the brain bugs probably the
biggest indicator we're meant to feel
sorry for them as it's got really large
eyes and very it's very chubby it's
almost got like a baby like appearance
with chubbiness and big eyes being
something humans tend to find cute the
humans are here to kill them though they
don't find them as cute as I do and they
nuke the bug holes blow up the tank of
bugs and get what's likely their first
real Victory on the planet they
celebrate that night echoing images of
the Vietnam war with beer football and
parties being thrown Rico finally lets
his hair down and he decides to dance
with this evil for what would actually
end up being her last night alive
[Applause]
[Music]
Rico the song in the violin here is
actually Dixie which was popularized by
the Confederacy during the American
Civil War this song was originally sang
from the perspective of a free slave
longing to go back to his Plantation and
it was something that minstrels adopted
and sang it was written by a white man
have to make that clear and it has been
interpreted as a racist relic of the
Confederacy that stands as a reminder of
white domination which could Echo what
humanity is doing to clendethe use a
James High TV actually had a great point
on Reddit and they said it's actually
very symbolic that we have black people
dancing to what's essentially
Confederate warsong they said it shows
that the military can be a great
equalizer and that things like gender
and racer put it aside when you're
fighting for a common cause this was
something that the Germans actually
weaponized in both world wars and they
used to drop Liars asking the black
soldiers why they were fighting for a
country that hated them and segregated
them back home you know there's a lot
going on with it and this stuff it might
not even be right but I love how the
movie makes you think and actually try
and look at it on a deeper level anyway
the music switches up as Johnny dances
with dizzy and Ace plays a song Las
golondrinas this is typically played to
signify AI saying goodbye which could
possibly foreshadowing the death of
dizzy after a night of romance we see
the Troopers Hit The Outpost where they
discover evidence of the brain bug and a
Lone Survivor at the base hiding in a
fridge is Marshall Bell who you might
recognize from Total Recall guys lost
his mind along with the rest of the camp
and we get another major action scene
which is started by this line
this is something that Rico also utters
is the last line of the movie and it was
actually a famous quote from our own
history this was shattered by Dan Daly
during the Battle of below wood before
he and his forces charged on the Germans
E2 was a Medal of Honor recipient and
the sentiments That Glory lives forever
and dying in battle makes it so that
your Legend is told in stories for
centuries and centuries and on YouTube
breakdowns of course now the entire
battle contains lots of references to
Zulu with Lion psych we're all gonna die
pulling directly from that movie in
these scenes there's just non-stop
gunfire and it turns out that morama was
actually fired in this film than any
other movie prior to it in total over
300 000 blank rounds were spent which at
the time was a brand new world record
whereas check orders Rico to shoot him
after his legs are ripped off and though
dis manages to score a hole in one she
is fatally stabbed again this is
probably Johnny's lowest moment with her
screaming Don't Let Me Go Johnny before
she dies and I think right hot take but
dizzy I I think Dizzy's probably
everyone's favorite character in this
movie deep down at least and having a go
out like this kind of shows the Folly of
war and how much it actually costs she's
the only person we get a funeral for and
it actually feels like a loss rather
than the Carnage in action movie Vibe
stuff that the films had so far
mirroring Kane's body getting thrown
into space in Alien this is of course
supposed to Echo a Burial at Sea what it
does though is that it gets us ready for
the Final Act of the movie and we want
to see the bugs squashed as much as the
characters do that's why Carla turns
rocking his Indiana Jones bad guy
cosplay and I noticed something very
subtle here that they do with his makeup
if you put his face side by side with
how he was at the start of the film
you'll probably notice that they made
him look paler and darkened around his
eyes this almost makes him look
skeletal-like and I feel like he's very
much the personification of the Grim
Reaper he admits that he sent soldiers
to their death to just Scout areas out
and this was to discover if there was a
brain bug or not now this is followed in
the next scene when we see Rico getting
his new Squadron the cast in this movie
are of course well well I like the old
Saved by the Bell thing where they'd
have 30 year olds playing teenagers but
here they use actual teenagers it shows
how young the military will recruit to
continue their war and this is something
we've seen in real life the average age
of a soldier in World War II is 26 rise
in Vietnam it was as low as 19. a common
ship is attacked in space and she and
xanda have to evacuate to clendathio in
order to survive really great action
Secret with their Captain getting killed
by a door another Escape pods crashing
as the pair barely make it out taken by
the brain bug we learn Carl actually
sent a psychic message to Johnny to let
him know that she and Xander are still
alive which in turn takes them to the
Brain book we see this when he's going
to walk down one tunnel and then gets a
feeling about going down the other
[Music]
now this could be read as the higher-ups
literally mind control in the grunts to
follow orders completely stripping them
of their actual brains this is a
mirrored in the next scene with Xander
getting stripped of his uh but this
obviously comes down to it getting
pulled out by the brain bug now this
ends up getting reflected in the humans
at the end where we see one jamming a
spike into it like how it jammed a spike
into Xander I remember I always had to
look away during the scene as a kid and
it actually is at the point where I kind
of have a black spot in my mind of what
actually happens during it which is
never able to watch it complete I
could watch everything else but for some
reason just there's one scene I could
never bring myself to actually watch it
anyway Karma manages to slice off its
sting-a-ling and she's saved by Johnny
leading to Gabriel's heroic death scene
viewing this as a propaganda piece you
can see how they portray the glory of
death and how if you die there's at
least value in also killing some of the
enemy
surviving we see the victory of the
brain box capture which is the beginning
of Humanity's triumph over the species
sensing fear the humans cheer on as it
Winters and pain which is of course
meant to make us have a Little Bit of
Sympathy For It Zim is Lord as the hero
and this carries a message that people
should step down from their positions of
power to fight so they can be a hero too
it's very much a propaganda message and
we see how this victories led to more
funding being put towards the military
they now have better ships better guns
more recruits and more battles that need
to be fought we see other Heroes who
followed have been promoted and even see
Carmen's co-pilot from the first flight
now under her Wing movie ends with a
very triumphant message for the future
which would also be something that
propaganda films tend to close out on
two they'd obviously be released in the
middle of a war so would have to end
with a feeling like victory was very
close at hand now there may even be a
deeper layer to this as well and
verhoven is tease at this might actually
be a sign of humanity using the war this
is something that we saw in real life
propaganda Flakes with the Germans not
really looking at themselves with any
introspection after losing several
battles things like Stalingrad are
mirrored with Clan dathu and its
propaganda that tells us they're gonna
win when we've seen a lot of badly
thought out attacks and tactics the
propaganda actually tends to ramp up
when Assad is losing so more people sign
up to fight rather than seeing it as
being pointless that's why I feel the
government might just be covering up the
entire thing and basically lying about
how badly it's going all in all you also
have to ask what we win as well and if
if this is actually going to be
considered a victory if you take the
idea that the asteroid was in fired by
the bugs and technically they haven't
attacked Humanity it's always been them
on the defense trying to protect their
home for the entire movie when you think
about it for the entire movie we've
basically been cheering on some Space
Nazis going to a planet to kill the life
forms there and experiment on the more
intelligent parts of the species so that
they can do whatever they want it's not
really a victory in the end if you look
at it through a certain lens and
Humanity's becoming aggressor that kills
and murders because we can't get along
with things peacefully in the end I
think that spells more Doom for us than
the bugs and it's an interesting way to
close out the film now it ends this
Classic Movie that I hope you're gonna
watch in a new light because of all
we've talked about today hopefully you
watch it like are we the baddies and
start to question everything and see a
deeper layer to it I've had a blast
making this video you know we got deep
on it um I know there's going to be some
disagreements agreements and stuff I
didn't catch brought up as well and I
can't wait to read your thoughts on it
in the comments below don't forget that
subscription guarantees citizenship so
make sure you do that and like the video
as well we're really close to hitting
200 members too so if you'd like to
support these classic movie breakdowns
then please click the join button for
the price of lesson a magnify slowly a
month you can get access to these videos
and it also helps to keep us independent
huge thank you to everyone who signed up
so far and we will be back with the
Return of the Jedi next week before
going into a brand new series I think
you guys are gonna love but either way
huge thank you for clicking this I've
been Paul and I'll see you next time you
take care I'm doing my part peace
[Music]